як звати українську дучу які складно
розбавляти українську то жертва ти
Маша їдь до Росії на
[музика]
я повністю забув російському
летить зараз
[сміх]
по іншому
навіть не зможу У мене по-іншому
розташований
я не зможу говорити на ньому я його розумію
знаєш у мене дратує
мене дратує коли говорять суржиком
Я тобі зараз дуже кулакам і видавлю
зрозумів сука франківського мені друг
розбавляючи злить нелюдину і викину все
затягну в нього пугана українського лідяного
людина я так розуміє ще дуже розумний та
вінка ж слуху і хлопчику Харків такий
навалявру з нею що знаєш нам вас
природу вашого російського
дівчина спис Дякую
[музика]
добре
Слава Росії
а тому що я Путін поважав
досі я приїду по кожному ти не день не
вийшли щоб я виїхав до Путіна я без
грошей
[музика]
на це можна дивитися вічно
[оплески]
сти Я бачив Тип тип Я бачив тип у Росії
Стояв в аеропорту з табличкою За його світ
[ __ ] пов'язала міліція там щось йому
навішували якусь статтю не пам'ятаю якусь
а просто чекав на людину з аеропорту за
світу [ __ ] я не знаю
подали в YouTube вона так думала ти Руні
аналог
RuTube для мене зі схожою на годину скубі-ду
хоче сказати YouTube захистити
російський рутюб секс YouTube
на яких явлено був через монтаж не вам
і так на Росії на Росії кнопка лайк
О Боже
так так Ну наріжте так
дуріє Паші відео на RuTube праворуч
був ще Путіна в рекламі презервативі
логи бразильська студія plato
рекламної компанії деки люди народи
ти жити хочеш Ну житимеш не ворожку
поїдеш а Я говорю в рашку житиме
а я сказав
українська Привіт
що ти мене відразу ображаєш
Не ну я дивлюся на обличчя я бачу, що ти
російська
я що Мухам не виснажені
[музика]
бо довбоєб Я розумію що вас не було в
Євробачення Але це українська пісня
виграла Євробачення і сумка ти не потрібна
в Україні [ __ ] пакетів
[музика]
на повторі до ранку
[оплески]
[музика]
що буде
радіанського Союзу сяде на фломастер
канцтовариш
[музика]
душею я до вас
[оплески]
[музика]
коротше прикинь вона вийняв
а чи потрапив на чи у сміху
ви просто гляньте нахуй просто [ __ ]
блювати
ми
виросло шоуни шикуються в циркунах в
школі
залишилося
мені наш оператор дзвони
[музика]
Слава Україні